let's talk about what's going on in
Canada and in Singapore before flying to
Singapore for today / tomorrow depending
on which time zone we're thinking of
today / tomorrow summit with North
Korean leader Kim jong-un Donald Trump
stopped in Canada for a g7 meeting it
was previously the g8 Russia of course
no longer part of it so it's the g7
Trump wants Russia back in we'll talk
about that separately every aspect of
Donald Trump's presence was an
embarrassment to the United States
there's really no other way to say it
trump showed up late he insulted a
variety of world leaders and left early
later sending subsequent insulting
tweets one such tweet about Canadian
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau Donald
Trump saying Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau of Canada acted so meek and mild
during our g7 meetings only to give a
news conference after I left saying that
US tariffs were kind of insulting and he
will not be pushed around very dishonest
and weak our tariffs are in response to
his of two hundred seventy percent on
dairy Trump then gave a bizarre rambling
press conference that was completely
incoherent during which he slammed CNN
as fake news and said all sorts of other
things that made absolutely no sense and
then upon leaving on his way to
Singapore he tweeted that he disagrees
with the communique that was sent out
wrapping up the entire summit saying
quote based on Justin's referring to
Justin Trudeau based on Justin's false
statements at his news conference and
the fact that Canada is charging massive
tariffs to our US farmers workers and
companies I have instructed our US
representatives not to endorse the
communique as we look at tariffs on
automobiles flooding the US market he
claimed that our relationship with
allies is a 10 and yet he's sending out
insulting tweets about our allies and
then most interestingly just in terms of
the like the flavor and color of the
thing the pictures that have been
released are truly embarrassing I mean
really indicative of a total and utter
[ __ ]
three check out pictures of Trump during
the summit versus Obama during a recent
similar summit you see at the top of
your screen Donald President Obama
rather in control in command clearly
respected as appear by other world
leaders and at the bottom of the screen
you see this picture of German
Chancellor Angela Merkel looking like
she's indignantly lecturing the little
kid at the table who won't eat his
broccoli meaning Donald Trump himself
and hilariously Donald Trump is known
for these handshake games that he plays
to sort of assert dominance whether it's
with Japanese leader Shinzo Abe a or
many others he tries to kind of jerk
them around with his handshake and
French president Emmanuel macron
dominating Trump in the first picture
I'm showing our video audience you see
Donald Trump clearly not in control of
the handshake you see a manual McCrone
with quite a grip there on Donald
Trump's right hand and then in a
close-up of Donald Trump's hand taken
immediately after this you can actually
see the thumbprint and the print from
macarons fourth and fifth fingers on
Trump's hand this was just moments after
the handshake and I mentioned this last
thing I get that it's sort of a goof
handshake games are really stupid but
they're important to Trump and by his
own standards of what's important he
clearly lost the game to Emmanuel macron
but handshakes aside another
embarrassing appearance by Trump
willfully ignorant bragging about not
preparing for negotiations with Kim
jong-un the world moving ahead without
the United States and there are trumpets
that are reveling in this as if it's
Trump putting America first not taking
crap from world leaders it is abundantly
clear that the u.s. is just being
excluded and is not seen as the player
it once was on the world stage and if
you don't mind that then congratulations
I guess by some harebrained logic Donald
Trump is winning but the United States
is increasingly not a player in world
climate change discussions and why would
be that's by Chuck Trump's choice the
dynamics of the g7 in Canada confirmed
that while Trump arriving late was
disrespectful and an incan
unions his presence was also a bother
and an inconvenience to the adults in
the room including very clearly German
Chancellor Angela Merkel realistically
the new leader of the free world as well
as the leaders of Japan and France and
Canada and the u.s. is being relegated
to a lower tier in the context of
international leadership period if
you're at rumpus then you see that as
winning well then yeah I guess Donald
Trump is winning but by any sensible
assessment the United States has been
taken down several notches on the world
stage and the world is laughing at us
right and the cherry on top which is
what I want to discuss in more depth
next is the the shrapnel that came from
this diplomatic abortion ended with
Donald Trump threatening to end all
trade with American allies let's talk
about that next the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as $1 per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad